turning overseas China is battling a
disturbing new surge of covet infections
a new study from the University of Hong
Kong warns the country could see nearly
a million deaths from the deaths deaths
rather from the virus this winter after
lifting its very harsh zero covert
policies Elizabeth Palmer has more
official horses lined up along with
private vehicles at the dongjao
crematorium in Beijing almost two weeks
after the Chinese government abruptly
lifted its strict coveted controls which
had included routine Mass testing and
mandatory quarantine at the same time
the government stopped counting cases
and as for covet deaths the official
numbers say there were only five today
social media says different for example
this video was posted by a user in East
Central henan Province while another
working at a Funeral Home in neighboring
said deaths had increased five-fold in a
week but there is no way to know for
sure the government has increased the
number of so-called fever clinics
essentially drop in medical centers in
big cities and they appear to be coping
they're for people who don't feel well
and believe they need treatment though
many citizens just don't know how to
judge after years of being told that
covid-19 is a dangerous killer while
many Chinese pharmacies are completely
out of cold and flu medication
State media is pushing the optimistic
View
in official videos reassuring people
that this huge wave of infection will
Peak soon and things will be back to
normal by spring
for CBS mornings I'm Elizabeth Palmer in
Tokyo